[Música]
hablamos de salud en directo américa de
france 24 ya está convenido en el
estudio más romeros a la mar bienvenida
feliz mañana del jueves y empezamos
hablando de un tema pues bastante serio
mari es la soledad un mal que afecta a
todo el mundo por igual mart pues todo
el mundo se ha sentido solo alguna vez
no así es nos afecta a todos por igual
si no ahora veremos los datos que lo
especifican un poco más es un estudio
publicado en la revista bien jay y
analiza datos de 113 países la primera
conclusión es que es la soledad crónica
es decir la que no es puntual sino que
se alarga en el tiempo es prevalente
tiene una prevalencia alta en todos los
países indistintamente el estudio luego
se centra en europa pues por la
disponibilidad de datos que hay que es
más alta que en otras regiones y vemos
por ejemplo que en europa del este- es
donde es la región donde esta
prevalencia de la soledad es más alta en
europa del norte es donde es más baja
bien algunos ejemplos aquí por ejemplo
en ucrania llega hasta el 15% mientras
que noruega es del 2,1 por ciento entre
medio y un amplio rango también de datos
una de las conclusiones entonces qué
extrayeron científicos que extrajeron
los científicos que trabajaron en este
estudio es que esta prevalencia de la
soledad está relacionada con el nivel de
ingresos de los países es decir a menos
ingresos más soledad mejor condiciones
sociales menos prevalencia de la soledad
especialmente a partir de los 30 años
esto significa que está muy relacionado
también con la pobreza con la
inestabilidad vital con las
desigualdades que existen en los países
los riesgos raúl que existen para la
soledad están más que comprobados esto
no es nuevo por ejemplo está asociada
con una peor salud cardiovascular con
más colesterol con problemas para dormir
por ejemplo y eso también con los pues
con la pobre salud mental que eso puede
implicar y esto llega hasta el punto de
que la soledad está asociada a un 26%
más de riesgo de mortalidad y es
precisamente por eso que tanto el equipo
de científicos que hizo este estudio
como el equipo editorial de la revista
bien jay hizo un llamado a intentar
solucionar estos problemas de escuchemos
lo
una aproximación desde la salud pública
a la soledad implica confrontar los
factores sociales y estructurales que
influyen en el riesgo de la soledad a lo
largo de la vida incluyendo la pobreza
la educación la vivienda las
desigualdades e implementando políticas
para tratarlos son unas medidas que al
final serán más que necesarias además
pues después de la pandemia donde hemos
visto que tanto la soledad a raíz de los
aislamientos como las condiciones
sociales han empeorado soledad ansiedad
depresión marc volvemos a hablar del
gobi 19 por supuesto la organización
panamericana de la salud hizo un balance
de esta situación y le pregunto cuál es
qué dijo si está bien que hayamos aveces
dejado de dejar de decir los datos día a
día porque será un poco soy de santé
también pero no está mal de vez en
cuando recuerdo que estábamos en trazos
generales américa del norte esto es lo
que dijo en una rueda de prensa la
organización panamericana de la salud
américa del norte ha entrado ya en un
descenso de esta última oleada provocada
por omicron eeuu canadá méxico por
ejemplo mientras que américa central y
sudamérica todavía están en un momento
en el que las muertes están creciendo
las cifras generales son las siguientes
esta semana se diagnosticaron 4,3
millones de casos de kobe 19 supuso un
descenso del 31 por ciento respecto a la
semana anterior eso es bueno pero por
otro lado se registraron 33 mil muertes
algo más de 33 mil muertes un 13% más
que hace una semana es decir que por
supuesto todavía no estamos saliendo de
una situación todavía de una cierta
alarma no es lo único sin embargo que
resaltaron en la rueda de prensa y es
que la organización panamericana de la
salud volvió a hacer un llamado a
mejorar las condiciones de trabajo del
personal sanitario en todo el continente
americano
por un lado asegurando que tengan
protección contra el cubit 19 que
también tengan acceso a las vacunas que
se prioricen para la vacunación y para
la vacunación de refuerzo pero por otro
lado también en términos de mejorar su
bienestar sus condiciones laborales y
pues por las implicaciones que eso tiene
volvemos a hablar de en su salud mental
escuchemos lo que decía la directora al
respecto
son equipos desactualizados años de poca
inversión malas condiciones laborales
hicieron el trabajo del personal
sanitario más difícil en 11 países
latinoamericanos
trabajadores de la salud mostraron altas
tasas de síntomas depresivos y de
acciones suicidas y estrés psicológico
mari como ya lo hemos visto también los
humanos no somos los únicos que nos
contagiamos con este coronavirus con
este con 19 en eeuu se encontraron
anticuerpos en los siervos mar sí pues
es un animal que de hecho convive tanto
libremente en todo eeuu pero que se
acerca mucho alrededor de las ciudades
esa puede ser una de las explicaciones
que creen y es que hicieron un registro
de los casos de kobe 19 en los ciervos
del estado de nueva york que fue lo que
encontraron unas muestras de un centenar
de animales más o menos del 15 por
ciento de estas muestras tenían
anticuerpos contra el cubit 19 lo que
pasa es que esto se suma a otras cifras
que se han ido registrando a lo largo de
la pandemia y es que también grupos de
científicos vieron que en ohio hace unos
meses aproximadamente el 30 por ciento
de los animales que están en esa zona
también tenían anticuerpos y esa cifra
sube hasta el 60 por ciento en el caso
del estado de iowa por ejemplo en el 60%
de los ciervos tenían anticuerpos contra
él como 19 lo que hace pensar a los
científicos pues que han estado en
contacto con el virus y que han
desarrollado esta respuesta inmune
porque esto es relevante pues hasta
ahora los casos de kobe 19 animales se
registraban en espacios controlados no
en un zoológicos animales domésticos
pero esta es la primera vez que se
encuentra una prevalencia tan amplia en
animales salvajes hay unos 30 millones
de ciervos de este tipo en estados
unidos- y pues temen que se pueda
convertir en un reservorio de virus en
animales que el virus mute y que eso sea
una de las nuevas maneras en que
aparezcan nuevas variantes de ccoo y que
ojalá se sequen y de ahí no se traspase
la realidad mar sabe que es un nfc pues
la verdad es que no por eso estoy
esperando escucharte y la invitó
entonces que se quiera aquí para ir a
saludar a nuestro segundo invitado